this show is brought to you by Helix
sleep
Helix leap is where you can buy
mattresses online customized for you for
hundreds of dollars instead of thousands
and the best part is Helix sleep is
offering our listeners 50 off of your
order on top of the 100 you're already
Gonna Save so go to helixsleep.com Joey
and get 50 off of your order that's
helixsleep.com Joey Helix sleep.com
slash Joey
shows also brought to you by Club w
right now Club W is offering our
listeners 20 off of your first order
when you go to clubw.com Joey they all
they have all of the best wine You're
Gonna Want at a huge savings it's
clubw.com Joey because they have twenty
dollars on your first order and we know
you hate paying for shipping so on
orders of four bottles or more clubw is
going to pay for your shipping
oh [__]
here we go [__]
it's the Church of What's Happening Now
you bad [__]
foreign
Monday August 22nd it's a beautiful
[__] day to be alive and you're
in it [__]
the Church of What's Happening Now
what's happening you bad [__]
Uncle Joey here
with my main little brother Lee syat
hello and our beautiful guest Becky
Dominguez what's happening from uh
map
the map therapy podcast welcome to
everybody I hope you had a great weekend
lovely I hope everything is [__]
beautiful what's happening Lee with you
oh I had a uh I had a fun weekend I
watched uh I watched the fights last
night of course I just had a
you know I've just been really enjoying
kettlebells I'm actually kind of bummed
it's it's uh relocating
so it's uh good to have any idea where
they're going not not as of right now
but it's interesting because you've
always
you've always uh been a huge Champion
for me for changing and and
switching up your workout and I brought
Paula on Friday to kettlebells for the
first time and she had done kettlebells
with us uh and she was better than I was
and this past week she's still sore
today from what I did Friday and I've
been doing it for like six months three
days a week so I'm actually kind of
looking forward to maybe trying swimming
or something else that you've mentioned
so it's a that's a lot of [__] for you
to do just to you know everybody talks
about cross-training
over the years you know when I was a kid
I thought you woke up and you lifted
weights and you jump rope right or you
were in and everything was good but now
they say these are doing that well I
always switched up my workouts anyway
I'm the type of person that gets bored
but they always said to do something
different you know that your body
recuperates give it a Twist like hitting
the bag or maybe
you know [__] walking up a hill with
maybe hiking I don't know what the [__]
that is you know hiking 18 Hills I don't
[__] know but you always want to be
doing something so you don't get bored
with the same activity
but my issue isn't boredom I'm the king
of boredom I don't mind being bored I'm
what scares me is change
and that's with everything
so listen change is for [__]
everybody's scared oh yeah I gotta move
next week
I'm scared I got the little alertness
going up everybody's scared to change
but just force yourself to put a pair of
sneakers on and go to that boxing gym
over at Magnolia next to that [__]
thing go to Groupon get the coupon
go to Groupon get the [__] coupon and
you uh they have something for
everything they got something no no I
know for a fact they have a group on for
that
it's the boxing gym right it's run by
Carrie not Kenny Norris something Norris
he was a professional fighter a damn
good one in fact
he's right there Terry Norris
oh wow okay and he's right [__] there
and you go in there and he's got classes
for an hour and he doesn't make you
fight nobody okay you hold back and
admits for people and it's something
completely different you work on your
breathing it makes you jump rope he
makes you do push-ups he makes you do
sit-ups [__] like that you go in there
the first day you do one push-ups the
third day you do three push-ups it's the
same [__] no matter what the [__] you do
right now but then you'll get there
listen man
we're gonna talk about it anyway so
let's get to it but the theme of this is
evolution and I was talking to Becky
about it I was talking to Eddie Bravo
about it I loved the UFC I love mixed
martial arts and if you look at my
comedy career
excuse me after I started watching mixed
martial arts about a year later my
comedy changed
because from watching
mixed martial arts I saw guys that
learned to depend on one thing
one technique their best technique one
thing and that's your best take me if
tomorrow Becky said to me Joey I want to
become a comedian oh I am a comedian I
want to take acting lessons I go back
how long have you been in comedy about
10 years I feature around the country I
worked abroad
I said listen go down to this acting
class you know you're looking for the
mid-range one because if they were
teaching acting if they if they knew
about acting they'd be [__] acting
Okay so
you find yourself one that just goes
through the motions for 90 days you put
in your mind
that you're gonna go down there for 90
days
you've been a comic for 10 years you
grew up on Lucille Ball
you grew up on a Carol Burnett and I
mean there's not a sketch I can't talk
about Lucio ball that you don't know
that shows me something that shows me
something that when you were a little
girl you watched those episodes you had
a dream whatever
so when you go to this [__] acting
class
the first thing you do is going to be a
comedy scene then after that I wouldn't
let you touch comedy
I make you do dramatic scenes I make you
cry and make you take your shirt off and
make you do things that would take you
out of your comfort out of your comfort
zone and that's how you become what you
become
when
evolution is [__] huge it's huge you
know when I was snorting coke I would
snorkel for three months and then I
would put in a microwave oven and
smoking a joint for three months and
then I would [__] put it and mix it
with crack with turpentine and smoking
for three months even with Cokes and
then for three months I would buy crack
you know for six months I got hooked on
crack one time in 91 you know in 2001.
even with my addiction I always mixed it
up a little bit you know what I'm saying
for uh six months I'm not bored with
your addiction yeah for six months you
had Valium so instead of just snorting
coke I need Valiums and snork Coke you
know what I'm saying what is that that
sounds like like the opposite of what
you want to do right it's like drinking
a [__] Red Bull with vodka same
[__] difference you want to lower
this mic a little bit before I give
myself a headache there you go there you
go [__]
so we saw a fight last night
first off I did not place a bet last
night and my reasoning was very simple
too many people like Diaz
I like Diaz too many people like Diaz
you know what I'm saying
but no no the line was pretty similar it
was like minus 110 for Conor plus 105.
it wasn't a big difference no it wasn't
a big difference it was just too many
people like Diaz and then when the fight
started I thought about calling because
I thought about child Sonnen
and uh uh Anderson and this is Silva he
would beat him up for four rounds and he
just left the last second then the last
second I saw a tremendous fight last
night
first off I saw a tremendous fight I did
not when they raised Conor McGregor's
hand
I did not I was not surprised really
before I said he got ripped off I wanted
to watch the fight again
but then I laid down to go to sleep and
I woke up early this morning and that's
the first thing that was on my mind and
usually that's what happened because
your mind keeps thinking sometimes but
you go to sleep
what you saw was evolution
you saw one guy who went back
listen to everything as coach said to
him to the T
he controlled his emotions he knocked
them down two times he could have
attacked on top of him and tried to [__]
around he controlled his emotions well
he threw the leg you know like Becky and
I discussed earlier I'm gonna fight
Becky I'm gonna see who who beat it
I mean I've studied that [__] tape
the most outstanding thing of that tape
is dosanjos's leg kicks I mean he
wouldn't even show up that night in
advance he wasn't even in the arena
I think even [__] Dana said one of
the worst things ever that night about
him that he didn't even show up he took
a lot of completely out of his game with
leg kicks so after that dosanos fight me
being Nick Diaz Nate Diaz whatever the
[__] his name just me being an
individual I look at my leg I look at
the blood Waltz on my [__] leg and I
can't walk for five days right
and even though I got Richie Perez
boxing even though I got a Gracie Jiu
Jitsu I go down to [__] La over here
I get a hotel room at this Hilton
whatever the [__] it is over here and I
go see where uh Alan jubaine works out
Saxons or [__] the other guy down the
corner there's three movies high schools
here right the Trump [__] tremendous
and I learned how to check that kick so
that won't happen again
okay that's what I would do as a [__]
you know what I'm saying and I'm no
genius that's what I would do that's not
going to happen to me again right as
soon as I walk into any kickboxing gym
the teacher's gonna go
come here let's do this I already know
why you I know why you walked in I know
why you walked in the [__] door
but I mean like your boxing wouldn't be
as effective if you didn't put all that
weight on there
so let's find a healthy balance so if
there's a cat stance and karate the
first people they teach is a cat stance
when you uh what's Ronaldo what's his
name yeah what's his real name whatever
son's father the first thing he teaches
is a cat stance what's a cat's dance a
back stance with the [__] toes off
the floor so even if they kick sorry
about the table even if they kicked your
knee goes completely up and down right
and I'm no [__] martial arts [__]
Guru here I'm just saying to you what I
saw last night I saw Conor McGregor
fight a [__] extraordinary fight he
got hit you know whatever the [__] you
want to talk about this cardio again I
saw people online this morning his
cardio suspect he's fighting at 168. you
know he usually fights at one [__] 45
150. right you know take two 10 pound
dumbbells and walk up and down the
[__] Street and then take those 10
[__] dumbbells and walk without them
tomorrow and see how many times you walk
back and forth okay that's that extra 20
[__] pounds he fought a tremendous
fight yeah he fought a [__]
extraordinary [__] fight guys and
Diaz came in there with the one too
and but if you watch the fight again
that eye is broken again again
the LIE is broken again he's catching
you on the way back from that too he's
catching you that's all he was doing he
was sitting there you know his training
listen his training
I give my hats off to his coaches
my hats off to his training my hat's off
to what he spent because any
professional knows to to make money you
have to
uh you know what's that expression spend
money to spend money but there's another
one
uh you sharpen metal with metal right
you know when you sharpen metal or iron
one eye whatever the [__] expression
is and that's exactly what we saw last
night scoring system guys
I'm no judge I'm a fat [__] comedian
at smokes pot I didn't even see half the
punches I was just sitting there [__]
looking up in this guy but I'll tell you
what I did so I saw two clean knockdowns
and I saw blood [__] leaking from his
head as a judge
so that's what I saw so unless you want
to count punches or whatever I know
you're gonna hit me up on Twitter Joey I
don't know I don't know how to count
punches but that's what I saw and that's
what the judges saw well percentage-wise
does that seemed to be pretty even
really percentage-wise percentage-wise
but uh Diaz had like 100 more strikes
really yeah there were attempts there
was there was a lot more attempts and
yeah but I can look it up it was
something it was something like he had
uh 100 he had more strikes in the and
more significant strikes than McGregor I
think McGregor had three knockdowns if
I'm not mistaken
um Diaz had won
towards the land it wasn't just the last
one right when he got him down those
last like 15 seconds oh that was the
take down okay yeah I told her he
knocked him down with his hand at one
point did he towards the fourth round
I'm not sure I don't remember he had him
up against the cage like in the third or
something I thought it was over then he
was he was lighting him up really good I
thought I thought it was gonna be done
then
you know Jiu Jitsu was not even brought
upon in this fight oh no
me
and I understand I'm like tell people
don't text me why is that because it's
my world right it's my [__]
World okay and you don't want the same
thing Conor McGregor imposed
his world yeah
his world he took him down one time with
15 seconds left at the end
you know unless he was going to twist
his head off it was going to be right
[__] none of that McGregor got
trained
he's and Nate was trying to get him to
the ground
and he defended it he defended it
tremendously so I saw a well prepared
that's what the word is prepared
I saw like uh when Holly Holm went to
fight Ronda Rousey I saw the same
uh Carlos conduit against Diaz Carlos
conduit
always they have game plan yeah and
that's what I saw Conor McGregor adhere
to and it's very rough
when you are who you are
it's very rough for me to tell you to do
something when you are who you are and
you're so my hats go off to him you know
I don't know the future I don't know
what's going to happen in the future
uh I really don't give a [__] it's got
nothing to do with me I can't lie to
know what it's got nothing to do with me
I just enjoyed it last night
I enjoyed the whole card to be honest
with you but nobody you know I thought
it was a great car some day Anthony
Johnson is going to be talking to his
grandchildren he's like I'm not [__]
global talk Shaver's tooth out of his
[__] mouth but nobody talks
about it because Conor McGregor was on
the card it's like a Rocky's manager so
he knocked out what's his name but
that's the same not that Marciano
knocked out somebody else so who got the
Press Marciano got the Press
but that's that's what I saw last night
that's you really thought Diaz won me
yeah no what about you Thursday to be
honest when I was watching it granted I
had probably about a thousand milligrams
in my first
reaction was that he won
um and I'm trying to find this stupid
card it doesn't matter who gives a [__]
but um
and and I know this isn't really part of
the scoring at all
but for me when McGregor is running away
I feel like that should count for more
than it does
just as a fan
um do you think that the blood on Nate's
face should count none more no well
here's it because it doesn't because it
doesn't well it doesn't but like Joey
was saying I think that's a little bit
more
the judges might take that more into it
listen man I cleaned your eye and yeah I
bleeds in between rounds and I wipe it
that's [__] one thing
when I keep watching you in the fourth
round wiping your eye as the blood's
coming out there was one if you watch
the fight again if you watch the fight
again there's one scene where he goes to
the corner and they wipe it and the
blood shoots out of his eye right there
in front of you oh it will split second
and they take the camera off I mean it's
a [__] Split Second that you see
purple [__] blood coming out of his
[__] head well he was obviously
getting he got hit but from what I heard
in the end and I don't know which fights
apparently he does have a lot of scar
tissue which once it opens up it just
grows no matter what no matter what
happens so uh
that was the only thing
I'm I'm always surprised after the
fights when people give their actual
round scores because I don't have any
I've never scored around no knowledge of
it that's why that's what I said I don't
know I can't say anything on 47. yeah so
I don't yeah what the [__] do I know I
don't [__] know nothing about that
[__] and then also I mean even though I
love Rogan and
um
on on Goldberg on UFC whenever you watch
anything with commentary it can sway you
either way so sort of biasing so nothing
not even if they're biased just that
they sound smart and who knows maybe
maybe they see something wrong in them
in the moment so but in my heart I
wanted Diaz to win too so that's
probably why I
was thinking he won
but I'm never shocked and I it wasn't to
me
a huge like
oh my God this is gonna be in the papers
this is such an upset it felt like it
didn't feel like it didn't seem like a
robbery to you no it felt like Ty goes
to the winner yeah which happens a lot
in the UFC and McGregor's not he's not
the champion because it was a uh
whatever uh uh catch weight
but he's the guy that deal if he didn't
win
I don't know what what like that's a
very interesting topic UFC if I mean
granted it's never going to happen now
but at UFC with Conor McGregor losing
twice the Diaz
would be a completely different UFC you
think so
I think so I think you just go back to
his weight class and go go back yeah but
then he wouldn't be able to sell he had
already lost credibility I think with
the first Diaz loss if he lost twice
I think that would have been I know
there's people walking around today and
thinking that Diaz won that fight and
they're [__] already done with the I
know for a fact oh yeah I saw the I saw
people talking about it online
people thought it was a robbery and I
didn't think there was a robber I
thought it was a sensational fight hard
for me to call when I did hear the
second call that was a tie
I knew these people saw the same product
that made me feel good if I could have
gone either way and didn't surprise
doesn't really matter because you
[__] on your way to work anyway
so it doesn't affect you at all you
[__] still thinking about who
who's gonna win Hillary or Trump you
know it's still not doesn't change your
[__] life it's so weird like let me
ask you a question real quick
this is how [__] up this show is
smell this does it smell like anything
it smells something but
no no it doesn't smell like dick
can you smell something Lee
no I smell the ball okay so yeah they
this is liquid acid oh Jesus mainly did
the bottom of this only must have ate
chicken or something like that when we
were smoking pot leave by mistake oh God
says this thing tastes weird
okay
for three days
some kids on Twitter oh Jesus did you
stop
didn't stop
if it smells weird if it tastes weird
it's not I mean he was sending us
reports and bios and whatever and I mean
this has to be like a Rogan guy like
only Rogan's people [__] think there
and then I give a [__] you know what I'm
saying like they get like because I know
that that even after Lee said that
statement he goes it tastes weird it's
because we ate a thousand stars he's got
gum in his mouth water reefer who knows
what it tastes like who gives a [__]
just drink the [__] thing this kid
went so [__] crazy I woke up this
morning two minutes I just clicked
because a lot of times I put Twitter on
but I walk away right I put YouTube on
and I write jokes but twin is there yeah
that's it I'm not on [__] do it I'm
not reading dick there must be a light
that tells people when you're on Twitter
or something no no because this guy
being that yeah what what you and Lee
did was not acid and he wrote a report
and then he I said listen oh go away go
way go do something with your life for
three days we're alive even if it was
who gives a [__]
for three [__] days this is all this
guy thought about was
what you did wasn't this
listen guys I snorted [__] Coke off
people's [__] do you really think I
give a Frenchman's fight guys stop it
stop it save that for your friends at
Starbucks and all that [__] I did
[__] drugs a filthy [__] animals
you're gonna hit me 18 times hey Becky
it was relentless
you went to Facebook he was on Facebook
he cares for you Lee no but it was just
a [__] like no take you know look at
there's these people that walk around
through there that want to be Johnny
[__] intelligent right
especially when it comes to drugs okay
and let me tell you something about
drugs
for [__] 20. let's pretend
let's just pretend
I started the first time I caught weed
in the city I was telling lady the other
day
I was at this Cuban kid Lefty Cortina
Lefty Cortina and his brother
well these two [__] dudes that that
their dad was a doctor
I'm Cuban doctor we would just before we
came in the podcast we were watching the
video by La Lupe this Cuban singer from
the 60s
that was very hot during the revolution
and
you offered this kid cookie shark for
Dick Cavett cookies from Union City
whatever the [__] it is
what are we talking about
okay oh we were talking about Dr Cortina
so me and Lefty when I was a kid I used
to tell after he left I got good weed
I didn't know me and my friends were
like [__] 12.
and he would say where'd you get weed at
we go over here in North Bergen
somewhere and go [__] that [__] get in
the car get money
and me and Lefty on you know any day of
the week I was in the [__] seventh
grade guys
would shoot into the [__] City
and we wouldn't just go to Hall when we
would go to the Village
the first place he ever took me to cop I
was telling Lily the other day that I
was in his car and he had the eight
track to wish you were here in there
have you heard wish you were here to
[__] up album
never mind even at the first time when
you were a kid right and you just smoke
pot with somebody
we smoke pot on the way over there and
we parked the car and we walked in
and as I was walking in I noticed it was
a [__] Church Becky
it was a Catholic Church
Fridays they would do Bingo on the one
side of the hall and the priest on
Saturdays would rent out the other side
of the halter there's two weed salesmen
and on the picnic table they would just
lay out weed and in those days they had
three types of weed back here they had a
green weed Thai weed
but they had these little [__] square
uh three inch maybe four inch by one
inch weed that was compressed and dipped
in hash oil guys it's like 2 [__] 78
I'm telling you
you know I mean this shit's crazy so tip
this is my first experience with weed
for years I went to the Bronx the cop
Coke for you you know after a while
people think it's cool it's hit it's hip
right like the kids I was growing up
I'll go to the Bronx to cop Coke yeah
it's great Coke and you save it for five
hours but you're also gonna get mugs
someday or you know I don't give a [__]
if it was if it was two percent Purity
and I could buy it up the corner from my
house I'm not driving back with an eight
ball when I could walk down the [__]
corner and not get stopped you know so
when it comes to drugs man that's one
thing I don't know about weights I don't
know about [__] the moon and I don't
know about hunting I don't know about a
lot of [__] but I know there's the
carpet four in the [__] morning in
Harlem or in the Bronx and you got two
thousand dollars in your pocket so if
you haven't done that do me a favor shut
the [__] up just shut the [__] up just
shut the [__] up you know what it is to
walk up a third store [__] building
with bonehead at four in the afternoon
to get heroin when I was [__] 17 or
18. have you done that then shut the
[__] up have you gone to a black black
[__] neighborhood in Elizabeth New
Jersey next to [__] Newark on the
edge of [__] Newark the cop no then
shut the [__] up then what the [__] do
you know you're sending me paperwork or
they read that book by [__] the dude
who did mushrooms and I'm supposed to be
impressed I never read that [__] book
about the dude with the [__]
mushrooms what's his name what's his
name Timothy Lair well I don't even
[__] know none of these idiots I
don't read none of that [__] you know
why because I did my own [__] book I
live my own [__] book I did my own
[__] drugs I started [__] angel
duster when in the eighth grade you're
gonna come to me with your story about
it doesn't smell like acid 80 [__]
times on here I'm sorry Becky I get
emotional about that [__] the [__] is
wrong with people
and he kept on and I even Lee said to me
you know who this [__] kid is
he won't stop do you know what it is are
you familiar I understand I mean are you
being tagged in these yeah I'm being
tagged it's cool I mean it's
no one has any reference for what we're
doing on this that's I think that's a
part of the people and some people do
when they get real like really
passionate it's like almost like jiu
jitsu they're really passionate no no
there was only one person who caught
that everybody listened to that box oh
yeah yeah and he was relentless about it
oh yeah
relentless
now we're still alive and three days
later he's still [__] going we did
the acid Monday correct yeah sure yeah
Monday it's a [__] Sunday and he's
still sending me stupid [__] tweets
about chemicals it's [__] acid the
guy who gave it to us came back to the
show did he not leave he did yeah he did
and what did he [__] whisper to the
both of us only take one yeah that's
what he [__] said so do me a favor
mind your [__] business
yeah go do some acid and join the real
[__] world unbelievable
unbelievable
if Lee said that on the podcast I would
hear it and I would maybe send it to him
one time and let's read this you said it
didn't smell like acid and then you
would respond no no I just ate a garlic
cookie and that's it we move on with our
[__] lies
but there's some people take every
[__] word so literally I'm like
everything's over there and they [__]
run with it
even last night after the fights oh my
God
the post that I was seeing about
how terrible the judging and the how we
got robbed and oh there was one guy that
just would he was very very upset that
was the reason why I joined Jujitsu that
was the other 10 of the reason I joined
Jiu Jitsu yeah so I had the right to
raise my hand
you know what I'm saying like when you
read a sports writer you got to ask them
that was the last time you got the
Octagon when was the last time you went
to a Muay Thai class I agree to
understand what these people go through
when was the last time you talked to
Herb Dean on a plane or sent her being a
[__] email and Adam explained I had
him explain both the judging system on
it did we Nutley yeah uh him and uh him
and the other [__] guy John John
McCarthy I had him explain it on here
because I wanted people to understand
before they kept opening their [__]
mouths about this [__] and all the
variables that go into it right that's
the reason why I had those two guys
specifically because I get sick of
reading that [__] like everybody's a
[__] Authority now get them you know
it just kills me so who knows what they
saw I mean part of their frustration not
sure if they lost they lost money
I'm like I said I'm stupid do they give
you points for leg kicks why wouldn't
they okay then what the [__] how many
leg kicks did McGregor hit him with 92
how many I would think they would uh no
I don't know that's how [__] dumb I
am okay that's how dumb I am so that's
the school of thought I come from
I would I would imagine that would have
been counted with the Striking or is
that not is it I mean
I mean I just uh
I try and I just trying I keep on the
ground yeah what Conor was trying to
avoid yesterday that's where that's what
I like wish that I knew more about it so
I could set an argument or but I don't
and you know what and part of me doesn't
really want to know about it yeah
because I don't know what else to watch
for like like Lee was saying they're
backing up when he kept back he was
running you know what I looked up he
would turn it back to him and run I
looked at this well there was in the
third and fourth round but in the one
first and the second round he was doing
it to conserve energy right yeah he
would do it to have his guard down
though and they can serve that's how I
saw it yeah I didn't see it as running I
I definitely noticed in the first couple
rounds that he was trying to um
to to not wear himself out like he did
quickly right the last time that's what
I saw because I think that was part of
his downfall last time is that he just
he gassed himself out quick
George is not a competition you're doing
when [__] salad there's something
about this what do you got away in it 1
30. what are you weighing in now 135 God
only knows I had to I went to a little
party thing last night and went to a
baby shower today so
I've probably I'm probably about five
pounds away right now I have to call my
Dolce and [__] seriously
five [__] pounds of sweating it out
and [__] what's up with you what were
you gonna say my bro oh nothing but it's
uh this is your second tournament second
and third I'm doing two
in two days
I'm doing Saturday and on Sunday what's
Saturday Saturday is subfighter in Santa
Ana and what's Sunday uh Gracie worlds
well
wet I've come all the tournaments are an
hour away they can't have a tournament
down the block
um we're doing one in Pasadena but
you're gonna be out of town yeah
if you know anything about Uncle Joey
you're always out of town Pasadena is
out of town that's true
that's not that bad though it's right
there Patrick thing is not that bad the
drive to Pasadena is harmless it really
is yeah it's a nice town you know Pastor
Duncan lives in Pasadena now it's very
nice up there
there's parts of Pasadena we don't see
Lee because we just go to the [__]
ice house right that's the only Street
Old Town oh yeah is that what it's
called Old Town is there an Old Town
there I know there's something downtown
Lee you go down there you freak out
you've been down there right man yeah
yeah yeah
it's like a it's almost like an outdoor
mall the whole street like there's all
sorts of stuff
what's food the Italian restaurant
that's really [__] bad is there the
last time I was young no no that's one
of them but then it is the other one la
Lupe or some [__] thing
oh
ah no there's a lot of good stuff out
there
but no it's it's nice it's uh
that's what I really want
my whole dream
has always been like from the movies
like an Old Town Center
was like a main street and like a few
shops a couple restaurants maybe a store
like a corner store you want to be able
to like I don't know yeah but I don't
like
I love I love I love living in Boston
I've never lived in Hollywood because it
just at first it was too expensive and
now it just seems too much but like I
like Pasadena Glendale like those seem
kind of nice to have a sort of like a
damn Burbank has sort of like a downtown
Source scenario
on an area you can go walk around and
yeah cute with yeah go hang out
absolutely the worst thing the worst
thing in your life is living somewhere
and you don't know this you'll do it
once in your lifetime
is living somewhere where you don't
belong
did you ever do that yeah you did yeah I
[__] did it we've all done it for
stupid [__] reasons Sherman Williams
but no not even that like
you living in Hollywood you would shoot
yourself really within two months
because you're not in the business
you have no need to be there no not at
all that means you gotta wake up twice a
week and move your [__] car
you got to pay for parking you got to do
all this [__] that's what I mean like
like Ari shafir take Ari shaffir Harish
is a great guy
but if you know anything about our
interfere our fear goes to better fire
in the morning
Irish fear will take a train at 3 30 and
go to Brooklyn and get a slice of pizza
that's what laurisha feed does when I do
it not really
not [__] really I have a milkshake
and go to bed
when Ari told me he was going to New
York
I applauded him because he finally
picked a place that worked for him I get
home at one pick up the phone and call
New York
in town and at four Harvey sounds like
it's eight in the morning
he just walked in I went to get [__]
Pizza
I went to a pinball place you know Ari
you know but that place suited him more
than here Lee
yeah absolutely Vegas suits all three of
us today we could get a job we don't
have to be involved in Vegas and we like
Jiu Jitsu it's big there now you know
yeah
a lot of [__] for youth to do that but
this place is where you wouldn't have
nothing to do with
you know if you lived in Hollywood yeah
it would be cool for three months how
many nights a week do you stay out past
[__] 11. when we do the podcast and
we've been here when I go to comedy
clubs okay
so beside that that's the only Advantage
you would have is that you would walk to
the comedy club hello I would have
picked you up and go you know what I'm
saying like that's the only real
Advantage you had when I lived in
Hollywood I went to [__] six
auditions a week
I went to spots my spot's aware the
store the Laugh Factory so it paid for
me to [__] do it but even then like
the thing about living in the city like
with Ari or like in Boston
you don't need a car
to live with and with a car I love you
with all my heart
okay and let's knock something [__]
off okay you always need a [__]
car in today's world
I don't give a [__] what they tell you
okay I don't give a [__] what they tell
you you don't need a car in New York but
what if Isis drops a [__] bomb and
there's no trains what the [__] are you
gonna do with public transportation you
want to have a card somewhere
even if it's in a [__] garage in
Jersey you want to have a car somewhere
that's [__] you know I love that I
love that thought I lived it I lived
okay if you lived in Manhattan you
probably buy like a 2005. no I live
straight up and there's no no no I lived
in New York
from Jesus Christ but I went back as a
[__] employee in 90 [__] three for
a year
and I borrowed cars like I rented cars
because I just knew I found the guy that
happened a few months ago
fill up the tank and leave don't [__]
Dent the car so it was easy for me to
get a car and shoot up to a gig to go do
a gig or to go down the shore or
something like that but you always need
a [__] car like somewhere yeah if I
lived in New York today what am I gonna
do sell my Subaru
I'd probably have them in my garage
three days a week because I'm that
fortunate
to have a garage maybe if I could even
afford a house in Jersey but but
I would I would use a little public
transportation
but you could just use public
transportation for so long let me tell
you something when you're sitting on
public transportation your dream is to
get off of public oh yeah okay
absolutely okay there's some people
Paula Paula was born and raised here oh
yeah
Cuban Jane over here was born and raised
here
it don't mean nothing to Becky
to get up on a Sunday and drive to Santa
Ana to roll for an hour
and then come back wash a [__] and
shoot up to work doesn't mean nothing to
Becky I have friends
that live in uh what's next to Pasadena
if you stay on that [__] 134 after
you pass pass a deal on the 210. not
that story but where the track is they
have a name for that [__] time oh
like Monrovia okay Monrovia
I have a friend that lives in Monrovia
uh-huh four kids okay you know where
their family lives by the Ontario Improv
oh that's just down yeah yeah just just
damn that's just down a [__] hour
with no [__] no no no they're living
okay yeah
they go down there every Saturday and
Sunday yeah
be without Filipinos or every Saturday
it's somebody's birthday you know they
got 85 [__] kids it's somebody's
birthday right it's always somebody's
birthday and somebody's always
Catholicism might talk to them all the
time
but every Saturday and Sunday
they drive to Temecula like nothing
I have my friends in Pasadena they go to
Disneyland like I go to the [__]
jiu jitsu
with their kids
I wouldn't get in that [__] road to
Disneyland on a Sunday if you [__]
pay me I dread Disneyland
I'm looking to move out of the state
before my daughter says Disneyland
you understand me do you understand what
I'm trying to do here why I want to get
the [__] out of here but you California
[__] you don't give a [__] and
you take it
and it's just a way of life you used to
it it's really weird I'm not used to it
at all I couldn't imagine working five
days a week
and then on Sunday I gotta go see my
mother in [__] Ontario she would die
she would die she might as well die
there's no way I would do it once or two
times and I couldn't do it there is no
way I could be in a car on a Sunday for
four hours or three hours
there was no way I grew up with it I
grew up my mom would always have to
drive me to roller skating rinks that
were an hour away when I was a kid I'd
go to school she picked me up take me
drive me an hour to Buena Park or to
Orange County or to Pomona from Temecula
how do you do it and I think I I think
people grow up two different ways they
either get used to it and they they're
okay with living that way or they dread
it and they're like never again because
I grew up that way I don't want to ever
when I talk to people they tell me about
the commute I could tell they're from
California are you from California yeah
yeah drive an hour is you
that's 24 hours in a day that's two
you're taking for me being in the car I
don't I can't even think that way I will
not go anywhere on Ventura Boulevard
yeah and I [__] when [__] it I'm not
it's gonna take 20 extra minutes for
parking and traffic I avoid Ventura
Boulevard
that's how lazy I am people do you
understand what we're talking about here
we're talking about there is a traffic
in Los Angeles that
and at the at the end of the day I gotta
tell you it's really not that bad
but there's certain days that you'll get
caught and you wish Isis caught you and
stuck [__] needles in your eyeballs
because you can't believe what's going
on and it's not the traffic
there's not that much traffic there's
nothing
where here's anywhere here's my theory
they don't want to go home because that
that's where my anger comes from is my
years going back and forth in my shower
traffic on the 405 which I
it takes about an hour and a half to go
15 miles yes
that sounds right which and it just it's
stop and go and it just takes and then
you'll see there's a map I'll tell you
exactly what it is it takes forever to
get to Sunset and then it opens up
because no one else is coming on and
being an [__] and changing lanes and
then as the exits come on people our
[__] when you're coming down
if you're and if you're unlucky enough
to live above uh [__] where is it the
101 and the 405 trying to go under that
or from the 101 to the 405 you might as
well kill yourself there because these
people either they're high or they don't
they don't want to go anywhere so
they'll be
a hundred yard spaces between cars
I've never seen I go crazy
I will ride your [__] ass
until you either move get out of the
[__] way figure it out man well
here's I don't understand it at least
make my way around and fill the Gap
number two okay number two
you grew up in California
what Joey I really like the [__]
beach
what do you mean well I like to get up
at six and surf yeah okay I'm just
saying Becky
then you move to Malibu and you you
centralize
your life around Malibu but I've seen
people who
live in Sherman Oaks and surf every day
and then to top things off they work
downtown
and I go how the [__] do you do it
you're in your [__] car constantly
now this what we don't understand is
that I'll break down to you is the same
is going on listen when I go home now
there's a strip called Bergenline from
48th to the 7th that was Cuban everybody
knew I was getting Lena
that's always been that way
I went back with my wife
we couldn't make it to 60th Street
without make turning on
you know New York City the the traffic
is [__] unbelievable you know on the
Kennedy going to Long Island oh my
[__] god
try going down to you listen when I was
a kid it would take me
and my little criminal [__] cohorts
it would take us an hour we would get
blasted at the bar on a Friday night
till three
then get in the car and drive down to
Jersey Shore
it was always an hour and there was
nights we didn't even stop for the
[__] tolls we were so [__] up
we just went through the [__]
thoughts [__] to call it
but now it's two hours to get down the
show yeah
two hours to get the Jersey Shore on a
Friday you leave at five you're [__]
dead you're [__] dead
I know one thing wherever I live I have
to be Central but
to where I work why do you think I don't
go to The Comedy Store that much
because I don't like the store I'd be
down there seven nights a week yeah
yeah that [__] Laurel Canyon gets me
dizzy oh does it really I'm on the way
down on the way up okay cold water's
worse but yeah both of them cold water
is worse and if not I gotta go all the
way across up the [__] around yeah I'm
[__] the 101 and that's a nightmare
any [__] time so I'm stuck in a
[__] dilemma
I do not I don't know what happened to
me with traffic one day I said I'm not
doing this no more you know when I first
moved it you guys enjoys are gonna drop
I used to drive from [__]
sunset
to [__] Redondo Beach for a
slice of pizza what why because the
[__] Pizza
was to die for and make a day out of it
because it would take me 40 minutes tops
I would leave Hollywood at 11 o'clock
and be in Redondo 10 to [__] 12
eating [__] a slice of pizza I take a
walk on the pier there but uh whatever a
little vitamin D and I get back in the
car at 1 15 I'd be in Hollywood by
[__] two ready for an audition if I
told you I drove an hour first you would
smack me in the [__] mouth
I used to drive to Bro the best [__]
pizza around here was down at bikini in
Venice when I first got here it was um
Pizza on bagel oh it's hilarious good
yeah but now they had artichoke and his
people with [__] mustaches and oh
yeah [__] you
they when I used to go there was three
pizzas and there was a Mexican chick and
then pepperoni yeah cheese pepperoni and
sausage but now because they got an
outdoor bar don't they
or some [__] well the place I went to
doesn't but there's probably a thousand
places that's the same place it's the
same place then
another joke yeah they put on a choke
and [__] them and [__] garlic the
other [__] uh chili [__] the the Thai
chicken [__] drives me crazy when they
put it on pizza too speaking of
um driving around our friend uh Jason
Tiba posted a picture the last weekend I
wanted to talk to you about it yeah
because I called Becky and I called Lee
yesterday it was a joke but I never know
what you two [__] so you're the
two people I called with those tickets I
got a call Saturday night somebody says
to me hey man
uh they called me up the day I was
[__] and puking out of my [__]
mouth when were you doing that about a
month ago after the surgery we got the
surgery I got that flu I got a call that
night hey are you busy tonight we got
backstage passes for you
to go see the Grateful Dead at the
amphitheater I would have gone back here
we smoked a joint eat some Stars you
know it was from five to nine then they
had at the mission it's a bunch of
people smoking pot they stink a little
bit but the music's good for an hour you
know in a way I felt weird because the
main dudes ain't there they're dead
right you know they quit or whatever
they retired you know Jerry Garcia is
not then I got my man Jan Cutler John
Cutler that looks over me but I I would
have given you know my first intention
is always to give stuff to people
so he calls me Saturday night goes
listen I got two tremendous tickets for
you
for the Rams take your wife on a date
take leave take whatever you want
appreciation who'd they plan to know to
put what the matter
Lee 25 years ago
we would have gone we would have had a
beer on the way there we would have
pulled over got a little tulips for the
nose
part get onto the game called the little
bedding drank a beer you know at the
game there's a couple more bumps nothing
to take it to a [__] bar and tell
everybody he went to their arms again
it's tremendous like we're better than
you
but I called Lee Lee didn't want to go
and I call Becky because I never know
what Becky she's a woman of intrigued
maybe you want to take him out on a date
you never know you know I got a ticket
for the Rams oh my God
I love the Rams is it my childhood team
oh yeah yeah totally a woman of intrigue
you know I never know Lee wants to go to
minor league football on this Friday
night and go yeah it was nine dollars to
get in it was it was it was I almost got
stabbed in the neck
it wasn't bad at all
so I asked Lee if you wanted rims
tickets and then I know it was 202. I
knew you couldn't get those [__]
things away last night you couldn't give
those things away last night only like
[__] you know Michael Jackson kids
went to those [__] things like the
kids he molested got like the
organization got a whole box of those
tickets I can't take the kids so you
know we've been molested but then this
[__] Google it's told me this look at
this I would have I would have
and I would have
gone do you believe this I would not we
just posted something I would have given
him to someone on the street
my friend Jason tiblets on the podcast
this week and next week bro
wonder why the Rams had a hard time with
attendance last
they were here five eighty dollars to
park 80 80 preseason first preseason
first preseason game
eighty dollars to park
that is I I don't carry eighty dollars
cash on me when I go to a game oh you
don't no no you don't need cash anymore
oh of course
when we went to I went to the last UFC
that was there at the Forum and
I was able to pay my parking with a card
how much did they want 25 dollars
that's kind of reasonable but the thing
about L.A it's
it's reasonable to today's standards yes
yeah twenty twenty five dollars eighty I
[__] knew it it was 50.
when I went to the UFC I had free
tickets
for Jon Jones when he won they were in
Jersey and Rogan was announcing and I
took the tickets
and I'll never forget we [__] them
parked
they were 50 [__] dollars
and then there was some behind there
that were 35 and then my friend said
[__] it I'll get all the tickets and he
took off he got high
remember that's when George got the
banana bread hit them oh yeah and he
took off because the [__] banana
bread hit him so he said [__] it let me
get the hell out of here that was the
night because he was pissed off too he
was like 50 [__] bucks it's got to be
a cheaper place 25 pisses me off
well you know that's that's today's
stand that's why I won't go to those
things
that's why I refuse to go to those
events anymore what are the [__]
Dodgers want did I just don't know
yeah they included in the price of the
ticket because a lot of times I buy a
ticket and then like the price of the
ticket the angels are like 12 now they
used to be like eight so they were I'll
I'm on record as not really enjoying
Dodger Stadium I don't think I don't
think the Fan Experience is that great I
I don't I think people show up late well
the one thing I'll say for the Dodgers
they have a free bus from Union Station
so what we do is we take the train from
North Hollywood the bus goes all the way
up to the top so you don't walk up to
the top that's that's nice and it's free
and it takes you it takes you back too
it was great now when you go you have to
wait along is there a long one no if you
go to Boston though how's the experience
at the stadium now at Fenway I love it
Fenway now Bill Burr says that it's
white as a [__] now oh yeah well of
course well before they've actually had
some trouble like when I was in high
school and college
more so College
they had like a sellout streak for years
like I think it just ended like a year
or two ago
yeah the Red Sox yeah
the Red Sox yeah the Red Sox are in
Boston yes I know
um
the sellout streak that was quite
impressive but now so but yeah so they
have the pink hats they have they have
the people I sat in the widest space is
ever
I don't I've never talked about this
it's it was cold it used to be called
the 406 club now it's something else up
above home what did you sit there my
when my dad worked at Legal Seafood okay
all right they had like corporate seats
it was like behind glass they had free
popcorn waders and I it was great it was
fun you like popcorn Everyone likes
popcorn [__] popcorn really I don't know
[__] popcorn
not even at the movies sometimes I get
the popcorn they have that [__] dog
they have the garlic salt that you could
put in the pot oh where's that
at the ArcLight I've never been here
they're like flavored Butters now they
have a stand It's So Fancy no no flavor
Butters they have powders powders they
got powders they have powder and they
have garlic and something else they have
onions something else parmesan cheese
and then you shake the popcorn and you
put it on top and you go and I bought it
for the house for my wife and the
[__] thing got hard and the humidity
something happened to the [__] planet
I'm so hungry right now that sounds so
good
but yeah but it's difficult
but it's hard I can't imagine 80 but it
parking is crazy in Boston but in Boston
you have the train this is gonna be the
thing and this isn't even their primary
home they're gonna be there for like two
or three years and then to move to
Englewood oh that's right they were in
that Coliseum I the last time I felt
anything
at a football game was 93 I went to see
the Jets against the Philadelphia Eagles
and that was the last time I felt like a
human being at an event ever since then
while I'm sitting there I'm going I
can't believe I did this for this ticket
I can't believe I paid this much
for this ticket
I don't enjoy the experience because the
whole time I'm thinking about how I got
[__] in the ass
so a part of me pisses me the [__] off
you know a few years I could just ask
Joe for a ticket for UFC right
and I would look at the ticket
and see how much the ticket costs and my
I would get sick to my stomach and I
would tell a joke don't you have cheaper
tickets I said this I like I always like
the top
the side on the top there you know not
to sound like a [__] [__] but I
always felt weird like those tickets are
1100 for New Year's and [__] remember
years ago when Chuck went down
no those tickets on the bottom are like
1100 during the year oh but on New
Year's Eve those tickets are 3 000 yeah
for somebody I went December 30th or
something went here or January 2nd those
are the fights that it becomes a
complete different clientele
that's why those yeah New Year fights
they always have to have a white
headliner they cannot be a Brazilian or
something I don't know is that a lot is
it's got to be Captain America it's got
to be
somebody who's Conor McGregor or GSP I
was just thinking about Gabe Alder Aldo
McGregor what was it 192 or something
that was was it New Year's Day no that
was just that was like middle middle of
December but it was one of those big
cards yeah but no the cards between
Christmas
and New Year's it's a different
clientele well this one was a different
clientele that ticket that I had I
almost
fell to the floor when I saw the ticket
price which ticket for uh Aldo McGregor
it was like December like 13. oh yeah
yeah
and that was also Weidman rockhold all
that stuff there were some championships
how much were the tickets they were like
it was like five rows up from the floor
it said two thousand dollars on each
ticket
it wasn't on the floor it was
five rows up two two thousand dollars
at eight dollars a beer
now whenever people tell me that [__] I
always think I'm an American family
that's when I get pissed off I think I'm
an American family I think of a guy
who's a mechanic at Ford
and his wife is a school nurse right and
they want to go to a [__] the kids
want to go to a UFC yeah they got to go
to [__] Vegas or the [__] pay for
these tickets that's what I've never
really understood but I think tickets
are more expensive in Vegas
than around the country I think they
adjust them around the country
to the something I remember noticing
that with concert tickets because here
they would be you know one thing and
over there another 50 bucks it would
piss me off because I played you know I
went to see Julia serving
against the [__] sixes against the
Knicks
Christmas day to me that's the biggest
ticket like I never thought I could
score that ticket let's go on that
ticket for 17.
scalp for 20 that ticket would be what
would it be now well when the Lakers
play Christmas day now
I looked at the cheapest ticket for the
Lakers it was 297 and it was under the
[__] fan
all the way up on top on Christmas Day
197 I'm sorry
okay again so I'm a mechanic I gotta
save a boy here to give my kids two
tickets
to see the lake is on Christmas [__]
day
that's rough man that's rough
and I know that you have to uh make a
profit I'm not against you making a
profit I know Kobe Kobe whatever his
[__] name is Harris Kobe whatever
Brian Brian is 30 million dollars a year
but that's your responsibility
what about the American family I mean
this country was raised on baseball this
baseball is supposed to be American
there's few [__] stadiums
that offer you I think the Bronco uh the
Denver has dollar tickets again but your
son's got to sit with [__] ex-felons
right
your son takes a glove they steal it
from him you know
this is what I'm also thinking about the
safety of the stadiums
you know I went to a thousand of those
[__] Mech games for 15 bucks
thousands thousands
thousands
you know so hey whatever who the [__]
knows I don't know what they do with
this money
I don't know I used to go to a lot of
concerts when I was late teens early 20s
and I remember some some shows that I'd
buy tickets to maybe a hundred dollars
to sit
in the most expensive seats maybe a
hundred dollars
now
350 bucks easily for the same show you
grew up in California
where would you go see concerts at uh
the Forum
no I I went to a few at The Forum I
guess but it was more in more recent
years but um
Universal Amphitheater
when that existed
um the pond in Anaheim which I don't
know what it's called now anymore
the pond in Anaheim
um
and I did some at the Staples Center it
was already around for me
but I went to a lot of club shows too
but but even but the bigger ticket shows
it was 100 bucks maybe to sit
way up there I remember scalping a
ticket off of someone outside of an
Aerosmith concert and this was probably
2004 five
for a hundred bucks and I was sitting on
the floor
I'm I wasn't complaining but now that
same ticket
when you pay the hundred for what was
the face value of this it was it was
pretty close
back then it was still it was still
around 79 bucks 80 bucks something about
100 bucks maybe 120 bucks
have you guys seen what's been going on
at the Olympics with pickpocketing I've
been interested to get your take on that
Joey
what did I say
no I'm just saying it's Brazil yeah
for like it's Brazil but um like they're
like they're just running around the
streets just like
snatching phones like phones and stuff
was that was that anything that you ever
experienced in New York or were you he
was the one doing it
because it's just crazy I'm not saying
that you were pickpocket but I don't
know
nothing about the Olympics okay I don't
know anything about the [__] Olympics
I don't know what's going on with the
Olympics and I got to tell you something
I got Mouse to feed so I don't really
give a Frenchman's [__] about the
Olympics
but I will tell you something
whoever decided on Brazil for the
Olympics
doesn't even read the paper
like
I'm not an international Traveler
and I don't want to be an international
traveler it scares me it just takes me
well that too but it just takes me out
of my comfort zone I don't know the laws
I don't know what you could do I don't
know what you can do right you have one
of the biggest events in the world going
to one of the worst places on Earth
where the virus going on
with a virus going on that gives
pregnant women that kids come out with a
funnel on their [__] head and men
that causes Dimension it started in
Brazil didn't that oh did it yeah the
zika virus started in [__] Brazil so
now it's seen in Miami you do know that
humans are going to swim to [__]
Texas now who the [__] got to go to
Miami I just bought a ticket to Miami
you better call them back because that
ticket dropped that ticket dropped to
two dollars to sit and they rub your
feet and they [__] massage you
because who the [__] gonna go to Miami
now but it's this pregnant woman I'm not
pregnant I'm fine that really doesn't
matter you're going down there to get a
stabbing and you don't know what's going
to happen maybe he gets bit by the zika
virus next thing you know you're going
to wrestle and practice with a kid
they're kicking around because his head
matches the map the corners there I
don't [__] know I don't [__] know
Becky but
you know I've heard a thousand stories
about Brazil over the years
they have to behave yourself but then
again guys it's like any other
Metropolitan City you're gonna go to as
a tourist
if you have tourists written all [__]
over you you're gonna you have a Target
you're gonna get robbed there's people
who wait all year for that type of
shitley
and you're going to be walking around
playing Pokemon with your 400 on the
phone these people live in those things
called the virus
they live in a [__] Hut and you're
gonna be walking around then I know that
something's going on that's something
that costs more in their house right
somebody got robbed in the Olympics and
he said he didn't get robbed oh is that
what I keep hearing there's a thousand
things going on down there that the
people were [__] and sucking what do
you do when you go to Brazil you know
I'm going to pray
[Music]
Brazil for nobody goes to Brazil the
[__] they're either gonna fight play
soccer to [__] suck that's it look at
those Brazilians they look like they
[__] suck constantly what's their
menu they eat you gotta put a [__]
thing on your plate and they keep giving
you meat when you eat that much meat
it's because you're [__] Jack vegans
don't [__] that don't eat that don't
[__] that much all right but so what do
you think happens what the [__] do you
think happens with 20 year old kids when
you put them all together right and they
all look like beautiful yeah like all
these Olympians were like yeah they had
a couple ugly ones that they put wigs on
and makeup and fix the eyebrows and [__]
but besides that
that you know I mean
it's a [__] poor place
to do what do you think's gonna happen
with the jam about that pick apocalypse
[__] half those [__] are lucky
they're coming back
I mean I understand that and I
understand the theory behind it but to
also like it's whenever I hear about
pickpocketing I imagine like someone
just like sneakily one running through
maybe going into one purse they're just
running up and like snatching it from
them are you talking about that video
with the kid like jumps in the bus and
pulls the phone out of someone's hand
yeah yeah way way professionals way way
way way before
I didn't know anything about anything
you put [__] together
when it [__] hails in Colorado
people pick up their bags in New Jersey
and go to Colorado and Roofing people
because it's all it's all people go to
where the action is late
people are going to know what their
action is you know we were talking who
was he who's the guest when we're
talking about New York in the 70s
when you walk down 42nd street when it
became it went from the regular movies
on the one side
then the other side were regular movies
and then as you walked they got the
x-rated and that area also had people
that were selling drugs
those people also pick pockets
those people also people that when you
went to buy drugs all of a sudden they
showing up as cops and they took all
your money so you didn't go to jail
you know uh the other day I'm at the
store and some kid runs and he goes
you're not going to believe it there's a
guy out there offering people falling
flowers
to play Three Card monthly winner
400 bucks
he'll give you 400 and then you have to
put in 400 a year on and play three cup
man together that's the quickest scam in
the [__] world
I could tell you not to do it but you're
gonna do it and you're gonna do it
until you lose money and then you'll
call me back and go can you [__]
believe that guy Joy I'm gonna go what I
[__] say not to [__] do it I don't
do it because I gotta take him for 20
hours when I was [__] in the eighth
grade
you learned your lesson
and they you know when you're in the
eighth grade you have 40 hours and
somebody takes 20 of it
you learn quick and then the kid next to
me God Rest his soul
came up to me and said are you a [__]
[__] don't you know that's a [__]
scam and while he's talking to me he saw
the card through his right eye
even the guy even folds it you know what
three card month is you know it's
because absolutely it's three cards yeah
it's two red ones and a black one all
right and he folds the black one and he
goes ready yeah
find the black one and they start doing
this moving the cards around the next
thing you know even the card with the
[__] phone that you folded they'll
tell you to follow it
you'll put twenty dollars down it's a
[__] red card
so what they do in New York in the 80s
and late 70s and 80s mid 80s was you
have a guy and a lookout and basically
your office is a milk cart
with a [__] piece of cardboard that's
your office and people walk by
and if 10 people walk by one of they
know it percentage you know someone
comes over two comes over three come and
once they start playing
then everybody wants to play yeah and
also when you get a thousand two
thousand dollars he says police you
throw a thing up and you run and there
you are going what the [__] what the
[__] you took me for 800 and you I used
to see it constantly in New York
and giggle and walk away shaking my
angle thank God I learned it when I was
[__] 12. not when I was 38 like you
did you [__] [__] with your kids
in front of you losing money on the
street with your three little mongoloids
there standing there going Daddy Daddy
what happened I saw a guy taken for his
Travelers checks
and I saw the same scam in New York City
but you know I saw it expertly in San
Francisco
on Market Street I saw it that they had
it down to a scam the difference what
were they doing they even had the cop
sit on it wow
wait wait they had some Chinese cops in
on it dog these guys were [__] brutal
down there so there's anything ever a
hand not a [__] dime not even one to
like maybe but you're in with me
so I give at least 200 and I go Lee come
over and play
and when Lee's up 400 I get three other
suckers that go Leo start yelling I won
I won because Lee's in for 10 points
right sometimes I got a three-man
operation a four-man operation
and those operations remember you popped
two three thousand every 15 minutes
so you do that twice in an hour
you do that twice an hour at eight
different locations
oh you're good for a while it's a
tremendous [__] scam
but the other night
2016 at The Comedy Store guy was doing
it up front
where people four hundred dollars
seriously people are playing it because
the kid came and he goes I don't know
Uncle Joey what do you think I go listen
go upstairs smoke a joint forget about
it go do a spot don't mind your business
you don't even need that [__] it's Tony
Bennett Lee
oh oh [__]
oh dear
how you feeling Lee I feel great
when
oh
why don't you sing it though
can't disrespect Tony back okay
I'm so into it
You Wanna Dance
sure
you lead
or do you want me to lead
keep it up Lee I'm gonna have you up
there dancing like my Lupe on that
[__] chant take it off you
little Jew shoes and [__] jumping up
and down
God [__] punish me for saying Jew shoes
I bit my own lips
about those people
[__] murdered your son you're gonna
stick up for them good looking out yeah
thanks buddy
so romantical
a beautiful song it is
should I hear what generation Cuban here
first no [__] yeah both my parents were
born out there so we're born out there
and then they went where from where to
where my dad went to Mexico
for a little bit and my mom went to
Spain for like six months before she
came out here no [__] yeah what'd she
say about Spain
oh she was like four or five she's
what the [__] kind of people these [__]
that would have Spain when they're four
years old well hangs like that
I don't know I thought that's how I
thought I thought that was what was
normal was people go to other countries
and then so she went there with her
parents for six months and then came
here and then your dad went to Mexico no
he was one of the the kind of Peter Pan
type things because he went with
um his cousins and an aunt how old are
they
14. he left his family in Cuba how
[__] rough is that they didn't come
until like 10 years later
a little more maybe
yeah my dad was like in 1970. so I was
doing all those Peter Pan kids right
Peter Pan kids yeah
they were doing that for a long time
that's how Ricky we call them kind of
pear that's how Rudy sargil came up in
that program where they moved the whole
family well
so everybody knows I'm moving so sadly
I'm [__]
picking up [__] and I'm throwing [__]
out in my drawing I'm finding [__] and I
find my sister's phone number in Cuba
should I take the car I go to the liquor
store
the biggest calling card they got is
five bucks
wow so I buy two five dollar calling
cards I asked the guy these are they
good he goes yeah
how long has that conversation last time
I didn't know until I [__] got home
they were like eight minutes
but we did get to talk a little bit
after about a year
because I ratted my uh Uncle out to her
you know I said you have a couple
minutes ago let me tell you what
happened in 1984 I came out here
my mom was dead I came out and asked him
for help they spit in my face and she
goes I know he said you tried to Rob and
I go I tried to Rob him but he wouldn't
[__] pay me what he owed me and I go
my mom sent them money and she goes I
know your mom sent everybody money we
were talking
and my sister always felt that my mom
left her in the states
but after we discussed it last time this
time she goes you know
there's something I got to tell you when
our mom came to me
she goes she was about to have you
so she didn't wanna
to have you here
she wanted to have you in the states so
she went to New York but New York was
too [__] cold or something
so she went back to Cuba and then she
stayed a little longer but
then she would leave me and you would
not her grandma
I always thought we'd stayed with our
grandma and she goes no you stay we
stayed with lady called Tita
that was her friend and your mom would
leave us a mom would leave on Monday
mornings and come back on Friday
where'd she go she go to the city and
she had a book making an operation at
the restaurant
and then she would come back she goes
she did that for a while
and then every other week she would stay
for two weeks
and she kept doing that and then one day
she came and she goes she's done
that she was putting you in school
in New York but she goes I went to New
York a few times like you guys do you
remember and I go [__] now
[__] no I don't remember nothing she
goes oh yeah I got the pictures
we she took us down to some [__] toy
store she goes you were wrapped up you
weren't even walking
so it's [__] crazy she's got all this
[__] so then
she goes the truth of the matter is when
she came to me she wanted to leave
because she wanted to put you in school
I wanted you to stay here
she was seven She wanted you to go to
school here I wanted to be a big [__]
assistant I want to be in your life she
didn't want to do that she wanted me in
the United States to learn English
so she took him
sister said I'll stay here
so my mom didn't leave it with the
family they left her with Tita
so when they went back and she had me
then my dad died her dad died they
shipped him back she goes no I wasn't
allowed to go to the funeral
so yeah we were we talked about some but
the main thing she talked about
was that
she goes your family is a piece of [__]
right up
I mean right on like oh you didn't know
that
well you didn't [__] know that and
she goes let me face him
when your family found out your my
grandmother found out how much money my
mother was sending Tita
she went over and took my sister
and said she wanted that money
so she goes I was raised accordingly to
how much money your mother sent
our mother sent you know what I'm saying
so it was kind of just uh
it [__] me up it [__] my day up
because
like I told my wife like I told I don't
know if I told you even told me this
till now you know I've never
cried wolf about my mom dying like I
never when I was like 20 I put it
together I didn't want to be one of
those people that was my badge honor you
know what I'm saying
I'm not saying that
uh my little sister cried when my older
sister cried wolf what I am saying is
my life ain't dick compared to hers
like my life wasn't dead compared to her
it was me waking up next to a piece of
[__] and me getting hooked on drugs
and my mom died at least I had my mom
for [__] 16 years where she didn't
and then she loses this mystery because
they couldn't tell my grandma that my
mom was dead you know that for a while
so for 10 years this little [__] girl
thought that her mother wasn't calling
her
what you didn't know is that the [__]
lady was dead
so for 10 years this poor little [__]
young girl walked around in the mystery
until the mother died until our
grandmother died then they had the nerve
to tell the [__] family that this
woman died why didn't they tell who the
[__] knows I wasn't involved on that I
was trying to [__] uh walk around and
be a man I didn't know what the [__] was
going on
did you ever think about going back to
Cuba when you were young
[__] no yeah I knew that one was coming
[__] no like when I was young I talked
to them on the phone I talked to my
sister when my mom would call
but it was the farthest thing from my
mind the only thing I thought about was
maybe going to Miami that that was my
[__] Cuba
that was my [__] Cuba after my mother
died I had no numbers
[__] numbers you know I didn't know
what to do I would have [__] call the
only one I kept in touch with my uncle
out here that sack of [__] but my
[__] I mean my [__] sister went
off on the Family
oh they did they tweeted like a [__]
uh
secondhand [__] citizen so she was
raised like this secondhand citizen
I offered the sponsor and get her up
here yeah just tell me to go [__] myself
really she's not interested in leaving
she's 60 years old yeah
says he's 60 where the [__] she's gonna
go now
I mean my my grandparents came when they
were
when they were older but but at the same
time their kids were already here and
stuff so why not like their fan they
were moving the whole family it wasn't
just
listen man the [__] disdain
never even told my daughters this
oh my one daughter has to know by now
one way or another
but that little one I would never
I don't want her to learn the word hate
I don't want that to learn the word
stupid as a young age stupid and hey to
[__] I rather them she say [__]
say hate to think about that emotion
yeah
okay
and my mom never taught me to hate but
let me ask them there's two people I
[__] can't stand
and that's my uncle uncle and my [__]
ex-wife I mean
you know Jim Jones had an out plan I had
an out plan if this didn't work on the
way out I was going to stab my uncle and
then fly to Colorado and kill my ex-wife
and that was going to be the end of Joey
Diaz you never heard of Joey Diaz again
he goes into a [__] jail cell and sit
there right I was prepared to do that
because of the hatred I have for those
two
and when my [__] sister told me that
when he went to Cuba
in 89 he told them that like at dinner
he goes oh no he's [__] up he tried to
rob me and [__] that's like the biggest
smack in the face to me like that was
[__] it my sister said that her spine
almost broke
my sister goes I hadn't seen you and I
didn't know you but I knew that wasn't
you
because I knew my mother I knew her
mother and I know how she was and how
crazy she was a Lupe
so it's just that that really that that
broke the hate back to 1987. like I said
when I was doing time I would call him
once a week and threaten him
in Spanish
you know that when I was doing [__]
time in 1988 I would sit there once a
week your one phone call no I'd have
whatever phone calls I want as long as
you had quarters you could have made
[__] phone calls okay but I would
call them in his house in Spanish tell
them that way
and he would think I was Mexican he'd
start telling me all the [__] he didn't
do
you can't do nothing to me that wasn't
my that wasn't your wife she she's not
with you no more she's with me like he
would just rat on the phone about a
situation I had nothing to do with wow
look he thought it was I was somebody's
Mexican husband or something is he still
alive
fact do you know where he's at yeah he's
in Glendale oh in fact
close
this whole conversation started because
my cousin
called the house in December his
daughter well the whole War the second
war with us like I love my uncle
you know what I'm saying you're both
have a relative you love him he's a
piece of who you are that's who you are
that's right
but the thing he did in 84 I
forgave but I didn't forget and whenever
I would meet him to eat with him I mean
he's my blood I wanted to give him the
benefit of the death it was still there
like there was always that pause where
somebody was going to ask what happened
one day I did ask at the language
and he got really nervous and he was
like you showed up I could see death was
in your eyes and I'm like you [__]
[__] you know which I was [__] up
when I shut up I was crazy and I was out
of my [__] bird but I was more broken
I was a broken [__] kid you know I
was 21 years old the Olympics
we're in La that's why he came here they
got a job at the phone company
in 1984
what are you gonna do things are weird
Becky people are strange you were like
three
yeah yeah you were three in 1984. I was
over here slinging dick already smacking
[__] in 84 carrying a gun I
came out here carrying a gun and [__]
now good luck doing that where the [__]
was I going so
you know I [__] hate it though
tried to put it together for like three
or four years and we did and then we
scheduled a Thanksgiving dinner
and
she called me and said he doesn't want
to eat at the house
so I said okay
fine so I made other Thanksgiving plans
and he called two days later and he was
just still coming over I go no Marta
said
he knows that's not what I said
so do you understand me one of those
type of things and then Christmas we
went to my other cousin's house
her brother
and there she was sitting in the living
room like I got a cousin that's always
causing more that one the sister and I
wouldn't remember how come you're not
sitting with the adults get in there
that was a [__] problem like there's
always something with her you know
really God she don't like the guy's wife
or you know I me and my wife went to
yoga with this lady for a year so we
just get lay in the air you know we
found that it's my cousin's wife's
sister
like after a year of us doing yoga and
calling her mom because she had two kids
and talking to her and whatever
so we told my cousin my cousin hated it
I [__] hate her she's a two-faced
[__] in it what are you talking about
what are you [__] talking so I just
told her that they go instead of sitting
here hating it's Christmas go in the
other room and mingle it's [__]
Christmas you're still sitting there
hating eating with [__]
three-year-olds with my daughter and the
thing going in here she got pissed so
she never talked to me again really so a
year later she called the house last
December and she goes listen
my brother went to Cuba and they gave
him an envelope for you
so I asked my sister what was in the
envelope and she goes I sent you a
picture your mother and your father's
wedding
so I got up yesterday morning listen
Terry
get my [__] cousin on the phone
give her the address here and tell him
mail the [__] picture
so she finally yeah she called in
December and said I'm bringing you the
picture next week when I go see my
mother her mother's in the boarding home
right by the [__] old people
restaurant
up the block from Alberto crane Jiu
Jitsu there's a mall
they have those old [__] restaurants
that is a McDonald's there's a Burger
King there's a Toys R Us on Victory oh
isn't that a language no no duparz
DuPage where people go to eat and die
I'm surprised we don't eat that
I can't wait for Lee to come back I went
to DuPont and had turkey done it was is
it DuPage no I walked out of a departs
is the one on Ventura correct yes yeah
no that's something else that's older
older old people but it's like a diner
like yes
there's another there's a few locations
in the terrible parking lot over by
Aventura and Laurel Canyon where the
where the um the Back to the Future
Burger King is where I'm talking about
Victory whether it's a car dealership
and there's a Cuban well we took Mercy
to eat for the yeah if you go the long
way there yeah there's a like a little
restaurant there we went there with her
one time to eat with her man
the [__] food even the waiters were
[__] like missing an eye it's like
worse than White Castle it's [__]
something from another planet in there
it's something
from another planet
it does seem like that kind of Diner
yeah one time nothing is eatable
the turkey is old the gravy looks like
[__] uh like convenience yeah the
stuffing was scooped up the carrots are
falling off when the carrots don't want
nothing to do with the stuffing you got
yourself a [__] dilemma I mean
everything was bad but you know I sat
there with the baby and we played and we
talked so the thing the housing is right
around the corners my point you know on
the way here on the way this and I know
she goes to see her mother she said she
was going to drop the letter that was
[__] this
August and they never even called again
so I hope now that she sends the [__]
envelope to the new house and that's the
end of that relationship with these
people
it's tough when you're a family member
who you don't like
because you're like I've been drilled
into my hair forever that in the end
this is the only people these are the
only people you're gonna have right
and like oh man what if I like what if I
don't like them
I mean so it's not the entire family
usually listen brother there's just a
select few I heard something when I was
a young young man that sucks
listen I know how it is with family
I've had family I've had Street family
and I've had no family and you'd be
[__] surprised who comes through the
most but
I heard something once that friendship
is the only thing that you could choose
in your life because you really can't
choose your family right really can't
choose your family you're stuck with
your mother and your [__] father you
know I mean nobody hates their [__]
parents you know
but uh
I never
I used to have this friend in Boulder
this Cuban kit Danny feebles I still
talk to him
good friend of mine neon guy
and one day he came over to me and we
were talking he goes you know [__]
Ryan my partner
Ryan says
that him and you speak more
than him and his brother and then it
really bothers him you know and he never
thought about it so he worked with me
and this kid talks to his Cuban Brothers
every day he's got one Cuban Brothers
he just looks fatigued a real funny
Cuban family really funny Cuban family
the father's dead now God Rest us all
the mother died years ago
but
so I those mushrooms got me [__]
giggling here
um that it's so that family isn't
necessarily your blood and your friends
can be closer you come up
came up with no family
so for me I understand the love of the
family you know what I'm saying like I
see it from a different perspective
would I be a different do you think I
live in California my mother lived in
Jersey at this age are you [__]
kidding me
I live around the [__] corner right I
drive in a bingo I go in and eat I yell
at her she'd yell at me you know the
[__] deal I don't give a [__] about
Darion what she thinks Terry have to
live with it
this is my mom dog that's the way life
is that's just the way life [__] it is
you know
showing people talking like you know I
worry about Lee's mom is away you know
his mom lives in Boulder in Boston you
know I understand it I [__] get it
you know like there's uh
I I get it but then I also I also get
the part of people not [__] like a
family man
but I don't like
when somebody passes and then there's
Feud that I don't like that's horrible
all those families should go to [__]
burning hell that's terrible that's
terrible that's terrible that's terrible
you know that's terrible
people don't like each other if you
don't like your cousin since you were
five I [__] get it you tried to stick
your head in the dog [__] I get it man
he's a creepy [__] he ended up being a
pervert so you're right you don't like
your [__] cousin but for uh
you know I just never dreamed of being
in this position in a lifetime
uh
I thought that when my mother died my
uncle would step up and I can't lie he
tried not overwhelmingly tried he put on
his hand and he goes if you want to come
to California we'll work it out
it was like he kept calling me going
that way yeah why yeah why yeah why I
want you know
when I said no I'm sure it was a big bag
of relief nobody wanted a [__] 16
year old okay that lost their mother at
that home at that age
but I thought family would have reacted
differently and
the the best thing I learned was that
your family doesn't have to be blood
yeah not even by a [__] long shot
that that that's a fuss and I'm living
[__] proof of that I'm living proof
of that my the people who adopted me all
those years
the nephews and nieces have become my
nephews and nieces there you know I talk
to Mike every week I talk to [__]
this guy every week and Bobby every you
know I thought whoever I could you know
when the time permits
like I never forgot those people those
people became my people and they really
are they're my nieces that's just the
way [__] life is that my nephews it's
just the way life is and uh
it just it just bothered me that my
sister said that that I can't even
imagine and again before the [__]
phone hung up because a little operator
comes on
explained to her that I wish
we could have taken footage of my mother
at night like
my mom got up like I did lately knows
how I get up dog when I get up I call
Liam we start going and we're rocking
and rolling and we're laughing and we're
saying [__] up [__]
but Lee when after you hang up are you
not in the shower and giggling going
what the [__] is my life become I got
this Savage butt
and my mom went like that all day long
on that McGregor Pace either all day
long drinking those [__] drinks
hanging out with this little crazy
person and [__] but man the last hour of
her day was brutal why why because that
day would catch up with her
that's when what's in the closet creeps
up with you
and I would see her emptying on her bra
you know like she would empty out a bra
she'd take out the cash
she'd pick up the receipts for the day
and this and that a knife
and then she'd take out a little Coke
and whatever the [__] she had in her bra
and then well I would see the
transformation of no matter how many
drugs she did no matter how many shots
she did no matter how much money she
wanted to track that day
no matter if the match won and she was
going to the World Series and she
already had tickets
no matter how good her life was
the last 20 minutes of her day were
horrible because she thought about my
sister in Cuba
and no matter what was going on
no matter what was going on it
overwhelmed her I would see it
I would see it I would see it sometimes
that she would have to go to another
room
and it would draw out of Tears that's
how much I would see it that no matter
what was going on in her life so I
stressed that to my sister I said listen
man
you didn't see it when she was dead on
the floor I could see what killed her
and 30 percent of what killed her was
your relationship with him she talked to
her all the time and she sent the money
every week they talked all the time on
the phone I mean yeah listen man in
those days my mother's phone bill was
300 miles a month
back in the 70s yeah yeah the phone bill
was always you just didn't give a [__]
no number one she called New York
80 times a day
her phone started at eight with New York
what's going on where's the action going
today what numbers
and then there was remember the number
come the Brooklyn number comes out at
three
but there's the New York number and that
comes out every half hour on the hour
you know so you call and get that number
how do we do
call back in five minutes he's on the
phone you know all those things
there's a lot of people listening to
this podcast you never
had a landline or another it used to
cost money to call far away places that
there was no Unlimited No unlimited if
you call the different area code you got
bang dog yeah there used to be this
thing Sports phone
we've discussed it before if you're a
gambler
way before CNN Sports
way before anything you know either you
had a radio
that could listen let's say tonight you
lived in LA
and you bet
Milwaukee against the Lakers you your
sister [__] the center from the lake
and she told you that his [__] hurts
they party they did blow last night
they're not going to be they're going
down Okay so
what we talking about
yeah Sports phones let's say tonight you
call your bookie
that's at eight o'clock how do you how
do you find the score now Lee you go to
espn.com yeah but if there's no back
then how do you find it right back then
yeah 1985. what would you do
no ESPN no [__] thing here
no way Auntie no CNN that gave you you
know there was one channel I gave you
yes and is this a televised game you
can't can you call someone no so these
are just yeah like games that you
couldn't [__] that you couldn't watch
okay there's no other basketball game
that you could tap into even hit that
score but there was a call it was a
phone 1-800
talk sports so you would call them and
they would go this is Lisa I had up to
the hour on the money every money every
15 minutes giving you the new report in
the NBA no first day we go all right by
the way for free packs go to
888-651-8181 and get your free picks
stop being amazing meanwhile you're
being charged by the [__] minute
and then they're going to go down a list
and you you can't pick which game you
have to sit there and listen to the
whole list
so God forbid you better Tuesday and
it's college basketball
oh my God and you being the loser who
you are at that time because if you're
calling Sports phone you're the kiss of
death anyway
buildings are falling next to your
people are dying you just wait for
something to give you the [__] memo
and you would call SportsZone let's say
you bet the Lakers Milwaukee and it
would open up good evening this is Chip
genery for call Sports and by the way
800-44-444 get free picks right now this
is Chip generally back here talking to
you from the World of Sports okay number
one let's go along the list of college
basketball once he said that your Tempo
was Furious and he would do it [__]
lightning quick Florida Michigan State
oh yeah yeah so you're sitting there
going Jesus Christ you're at a bar
there's music on yeah God forbid you
miss it and you're like and now to the
NHL yeah and not the late breaking news
you know and baseball China's ping pong
team will not make the Olympics and
you're like I don't give a [__] about
China's [__] ping pong theme give me
the score of the Lakers against the
[__] Milwaukee Bucks and they're
spitting out everything spitting out
everything and then finally the NBA
and all of a sudden they're like and
your game is last
and then God forbid you miss it yeah
like God forget what do you say 66.60
God damn it God damn it that whole cycle
give me some more [__] quarters will
you
that was the bartender's name is we
would be calling that [__] number all
night at the bar for 50 cents so you
don't really realize it it's when you go
home and you would call it all night
long let's say you were in Jersey and
you bet the Lakers Lakers don't start in
New York till 10 30.
oh no no you will [__] call all night
when you get home when we would get home
in those days that's the first thing
Mike would say to me what's the score in
the Laker game they're the only
[__] that could save me I don't
know what are we gonna do I don't know
put the TV on what's going on call that
call sports bar and you would call
Sports phone every 15 minutes because
what you want to do is get it in the
rotation
and sometimes you were calling him and
be busy oh your blood pressure was
boiling [__]
what would your parents say well they
see the 400 Sports phone well my parents
were dead but I had like Whitey
O'Donnell Chuckie mcbreen
I had like three or four friends in the
eighth grade who went to the gambling
bug with me
and what we're doing the eighth grade is
just call each other up I'm not like we
would split a five-time what's a
five-timer it's 12 50 if you win 15 if
you lose
we were kids
don't let me tell you some 12.50 on an
album six dollars and a movie's two
dollars that's a lot of money though I
still got three dollars to take Mama
over and get her an ice cream maybe
finger banging behind the church what
are you nuts or what
oh my God
they're gambling it in [__] high
school
the one thing my high school did for
some reason we were playing dice it was
like the whitest high school in America
dice
actually
it's weird I don't know look at the
shape of you yeah and you're talking
about dice is weird dice is fun for you
it looks like two ice cubes what that's
why it's weird because you can't eat it
[__] telling people the acid
smells that smells like garlic
and then you put this kiss of death on
me every 15 minutes give me a report
about [__] like it's the [__]
Sports thing so you got two tournaments
this weekend yeah but
um no but matte therapy is doing their
own [__] thing so you're really
working this podcast into a tournament
second hand and you're not a junior and
[__] yeah I like you got Victor working
it yeah maybe someday
no we've got
um
a tournament on September 18th in
Pasadena
it's the LA nogi open
and um and we're also doing we're doing
like these open map beach party things
and so the next one we did one the day
after the last DVI and we're gonna do it
again the day before ebi because the ebi
8 is on a Sunday
September 11th so we're gonna do
September 10th at the beach in Santa
Monica
and if you leave early there's not that
much traffic it's not that bad a drive
what the sound to Santa Monica listen
that show's done that anyway
I got shows that thank God
thank God so you don't feel obligated
obligated to travel to Santa Monica
okay
the SAT walking for parking and then
walking around with a cooler and
sweating oh I'm doing it for this I
wouldn't do that on a regular basis
drive to Santa Monica
that's like the other side of the world
it really is that's what it seems like
after a while oh it does yeah listen I
could tell my acupuncturist she just
never called me again
One Cheek of 10 years once she closed
her office because she knew
she knows which wasn't gonna work wasn't
she right here down the street she was
but she lives in Marina del Rey and her
office is in Marina del Rey oh yeah so
she would only come up here once a week
think about it from her perspective she
was coming up and she only had three
clients it wasn't really worth a while
you know
so uh
when she when she moved you know she
goes she's still my client call me
and then I told I call her for no
surgery and I forgot but she never even
called me I know this woman she always
called she always called him saying
always
to check on the cats the baby how are
you what's going on I mean this is rare
for her not to call but I just took it
as a
maybe it was just a breakup it was time
to [__] break up you know maybe it
was time to do something else in your
life you know
I'm not driving the Marines already got
acne still haven't talked to her no
it's the weirdest [__] thing yeah so
I don't know what happened oh fish is
okay
listen man she always called the [__]
house
I don't know what to do I don't want to
call and seem like I'm [__]
threatened her or what's that word when
you stalk somebody I don't want to see
him like a stalker I mean her and I used
to talk all the [__] time or
something happened to her somebody would
have read it in the paper and the cops
are gonna [__] call me
my name isn't my [__] phone right
they would have called and said woman
where were you on July 8th
you know it's like a Law and Order
[__] episode I don't know
oh Joey Becky is like she's really into
the social media and everything and
there's a word that I wanted to get your
opinion on like what you think that what
do you think about it a word yes
adulting
you're asking him how he feels about the
word adulting yes I'm asking him how he
feels about the word adult I have a
feeling I don't even know what it means
that's number one I feel like he's about
to tell you to go [__] yourself no I
don't even know what it means number one
number two
it's got nothing to do with me I guess
it's being a grown-up yes yeah it's like
what people who like the Millennials who
you hate that term are saying whenever
they do something like making do their
laundry they're adulting yeah they need
a pattern it's their way of patting
themselves on the back I adulted today I
did my laundry
okay
I had to get a job I'm adulting
I don't know nothing about those words
Lee
they don't mean nothing to me you know
listen Lee you get up you wash your
[__] you smoke a joint you eat your
cereal and you go out then you do the
best you can do every [__] day I
don't know if it's adulting or not
I know when I was eight and I would come
home in the Summers my stepdad would
[__] wake me up at four in the
morning
and I have to go to this Market
to get roses and flowers glaviolas
Cubans like garlic glaviolos and people
in New York like Latios in those days
there's this long three-foot [__]
thing and they have different colors and
we would get another flowers off so I
didn't know what though daisies and [__]
like I don't know what their [__]
name
but I used to have to take the [__]
flowers pick up these cases take them
into the castle offalonian 57th and
Hudson Street and then I would take the
[__] roses and take a d stammer and
with gloves on I would de-stem the
[__] roses when I was eight nine and
no summers I would de-stem the [__]
roses and I would get little picks on my
fingers and I would do that to about 10.
a little about 10 I had like a half hour
break and then at 11 o'clock maybe
around there I would eat Cuban food like
at 10 and then 11 would have to [__]
cross the street and they had a butcher
shop which is really a numbers office
but it was a butcher shop so I had to go
over there and stock the shelves and
throw all the [__] empty meat things
away now when I was eight guess what I
did with the ten dollars they paid me I
go buy [__] balloons or firecrackers
or I'd stick a [__] condom up my
[__] at that point in my life I
didn't think I was adulting I think I
was buying I was getting money so I
could buy [__] so I could waste it yeah
so I don't know what the [__] adulting
is I have no idea I didn't feel like an
adult and I was making 10 20 bucks a day
they were paying me they were paying me
at that that's a lot for an
eight-year-old [__] yeah I could make
150 over there in West New York a week
over there with them chopping up meat
and [__] I would never chop up to me
because like with faint if I cut my
finger so it kept me away from knives in
those days and I was just allowed to
throw away [__] throw away boxes and
[__] like that you know
these [__] people gonna give [__]
a new name pretty soon if we let him
yeah what's what's you know what it's
called living your life did you ever
just live your life without a [__]
code or without a [__] name or
whatever [__] emotion no without a
hashtag
is there a thing called you know I sit
there some nights Becky
and I go wow I can't believe I laid this
story on people
you know like I've made the story of
people like on a podcast or whatever the
other day somebody was telling me about
the what's happening I did this Irish
I'm like we can't believe you told that
story I listened you know what I can't
believe I stopped the story but in a way
I'm proud because I have the story
to tell yeah these people are going to
be living in a [__] hashtag in three
[__] years
that's it that's their [__] life bro
I see the amount of people that just
text all [__] day yeah did I give
shout outs no that's I I [__] am
that chocolate mushroom wasn't battling
yeah
pretty fun let's polish this
[__] that Shay Corey Layton Jody
Parish Chris Castro David represa Jason
seagulls Brandy Lynn John Cutler and Amy
and Dante [__] godzini sending
me a Cuban c d the other day to The
Comedy Store give a shout out to Jeff
couch give a shout out to Jeff
[__] couch how's that one for
you stop with the [__] shut up man
what's going on
by the kettlebells are they gonna go
flying tomorrow morning
yeah yeah I'm gone
are they gonna slip out your hand you
want some more stars like no I think I'm
good for them I need two more maybe
three more to get the party started
right
go eat everyone it's Sunday why the [__]
walking we got these Stars here we'll
pick up a shipment this week again
polish off the bag between the two of
you what the [__] look at that there's
nothing in this I'm about 15 of them
[__]
look at the look on his face he looks
terrified wow we already have eaten 15
Stars today let's eat some more okay
it's a good [__] week it's a holiday
I don't even know when I come back yes
what holiday is it it's a Cuban follow
that oh we're gonna celebrate you're
gonna be like this uh this is the week
that I get to go to San Diego for the
juice to jump up and down I'm sorry what
what day you doing lately for the juice
to jump up and down we're going down
Thursday night Friday and then we'll
come back Saturday really is that so are
you taking any drugs with you or
anything never are you gonna go down
there like a [__] half a [__] Army
like you did last time no of course
we'll take some Stars
my little Cuban princess over here how
you dance at those things
uh yeah yeah yeah I think you made me do
it before too I do enjoy your dancing
yeah yeah see you've never done the
dance after the podcast we're gonna put
that [__] music on and you're gonna
do a little dance for her I'm sure
you're gonna do like like some wedding
like Jewish wedding stuff no no no this
is a band the Techno band and one of
those and jumps up and down you never
knew that about me
uh
wait do you see this one we made it many
Mysteries yeah God I give them [__]
stars yeah you are
I can't believe he used to go to those
things straight
not even alcohol dump he would sit in
the back look at this look at them I
would just sit there and mingle who the
[__] are you gonna mingle who would the
[__] would want to mingle with you he
also used to not speak to anybody so
I remember yeah I remember those days he
goes through those concerts with shirts
like that like he Suge Knight's
assistant and then he's got a [__]
water bottle who wants to talk to him
you know show up with a [__] cocktail
with a straw in it or umbrella or
something
huh
and we know he wasn't gonna be he's a
handsome [__] I'm a dork through
him through no you're not a dog yes I am
I could just imagine you gotta go show
up at those characters with a big blunt
like Snoop Dogg and they're all looking
like what the [__] is he thinking that's
right [__] this is what I'm
thinking [__] give me the
paperwork will you
so when is the tournament this week
you're doing you now you're still a blue
belt or purple belt look at you you bad
mother it'll be a year next week because
I got my glue about how many stripes did
he give you already he didn't do Stripes
he don't do Stripes it's just a surprise
the one one day he's gonna come out with
that purple belt and he's gonna say my
name and that's that's gonna be it you
like going to see Master Eddie yeah yeah
you like it over there that's the most
important thing that you like what the
[__] you're going that's when you're
doing the two tournaments this week so
yeah Saturday you're doing which one
subfighter in Santa Ana sub fighter
Santa Ana and Sunday is the world crazy
world that's a good one rose Grace
you'll be down there [__] yeah
everybody'll be doing that thing now
what weight do you have to go at I
thought a bug Landon on your home it was
a little love beauty mark you have that
I never saw
um that's amazing you've been sitting
here for an hour never saw that beauty
mark before the muscular Show Business
uh 1 30 on Saturday
on Saturday and then on Sunday it's
there's only two women's divisions 135
below and then 136 and up so let's see
you can eat that night I'm weighing in
on Friday night so I'm going directly to
in and out as soon as I'm done
absolutely but you want to stay on the
136 or another 130 you'll never make it
no no because the one Sunday is 1 30.
well that's no that one's 135. oh okay
so I can I can go eat yeah perfect
perfect now the one that you guys are
doing better part of math therapy what's
that weight level those were doing MMA
weight classes so it's gonna be the 115
one for the women 115 125 130 30. it's
just a woman's tournament no there's men
okay and it's the same thing one I think
that one starts at 120. he's out on the
beach too no that's in Pasadena I hope
not no [__] sand on my toes I got a
maneuver with sand on my toes but I
gotta go for the football with [__]
sand on his toes never mind that [__]
little strip of meat that's hanging from
his calf God knows what the [__] that is
that's gonna be at a CrossFit gym in
Pasadena that has plenty of mad space
and what's up in your world are you just
gonna sit there and not back and forth
like a Swami from salami you're gonna
talk and you gotta hand that you got a a
fight in this [__] a dog in this fight
what's up with you no I'm doing good
like I said in the last episode I
launched a new website which has gone
great
and that's it that's what's going on
that's all I'm doing right now man and
podcast I'm trying to work out podcasts
I'm I'm doing the math podcast with
Becky and Donna Gonzalez
in the house it's your favorite one
right I mean aside from this one
absolutely and then
that's it just that's what I'm doing
well it might be the toy you don't like
this uh I thought myself my [__] life
I was really just shooting a gun until
[__] it my life I'm glad I can inspire
you you don't inspire me when you're out
doing [__] you're a young man you should
be out mingling and [__] you know what
I'm saying flamingo
I'm not much of a mingler no yeah I was
anyway it's like the opposite of you let
me talk to you people about something
this Friday I'm moving and uh I got a
mattress
and I showed my wife this Helix sleep
and she looked at it and she came back
and she goes you got to get this
mattress because you're [__]
different you like sleeping on one side
you like it hard or soft and my wife
likes it medium so she looked at the
[__] matches we got the code from
Helix sleep we kind of deal with them
and we're trying the mattress out
exactly like that you know why because
you're unique you don't walk like
everyone you don't talk like everyone
you don't sleep like everyone so why is
your mattress one size fits all you ever
think about that because a custom
mattress will cost you five to ten
thousand bucks that's why until now
we're gonna introduce Helix sleep to you
where you could buy a mattress online
customized for hundreds of dollars
instead of thousands okay first off you
go to helixsleep.com you answer a few
simple questions based on four key
preferences and the result will be a
custom sleep profile used to build you
the most comfortable mattress you'll
ever sleep on okay your mattress will
arrive at your door in about a week and
shipping you ready for this one it's 100
free because that's what usually kills
you after the and for couples Helix
customizes each side of the mattress
that's what I'm talking about Helix
customers report a thirty percent thirty
percent Improvement in Sleep Quality you
have a hundred nights to try it out and
if you don't love it they'll pick it up
for free and give you a hundred percent
refund no questions asked okay the other
reason why everyone from GQ Magazine to
Forbes are talking about this Helix
mattress from Helix sleep so do me a
favor cut this [__] go to helixsleep.com
Joey I'm gonna give you 50 off your
order again
that's Helix Helix sleep.com slash Joey
j-o-e-y I'm Gonna Give You fifty dollars
off your order again
helixsleep.com Joey it's time that you
started sleeping correctly okay I'm
trying to get you sleep people don't
know the importance of sleep you got to
shoot me matches you wake up your back's
[__] up your neck's [__] up you
can't sleep right how you gonna perform
the next day at work how's your girl
gonna like you and be walking around
angry [__] that [__] go to
helixsleep.com slash Joey right now and
open up your world we're gonna give you
15 off your first matches who's better
than us huh it's a [__] Sunday night
we're coming on to you so when you wake
up tomorrow right now you're waking up
you're going Jesus Christ then [__]
god Joey and Lee and Becky [__]
welcome this and I got better news
it's Monday Labor day's two three weeks
away whatever the [__] it is I'm not big
on holidays I don't give a [__] every
day we work here seven days a week who
gives a [__] I don't know the last time
I woke up and said oh we have Monday oh
I don't give a [__] I work every day
[__] it that's the only way you get
ahead you want to [__] live like the
rest of the people and take the day off
do that [__] Savages we work every day
immigrants we work every [__] day we
don't give a [__] Monday Tuesday
Thursday Saturday Wednesday
we're working what is it if it ends in
day yeah we'll work I don't give a [__]
so everybody's gonna be partying all
right everybody wants to have a good
time
everybody wants to rock and roll you
know most of the parties you go to I
mean some people are savages
some of the people hang out with they
got no class you can walk in there with
a 12-pack they don't give a [__] but if
you want to mingle with the upper class
people you want to talk to nice people
sometimes you got to show up with a
bottle of wine
yeah it's nice to show up one of those
[__] boxes of wine and then people
drink that [__] and they get a headache
they wake up with a headache and now
they're cursing your [__] name so you
try to
be Joy bananas and you you know I mean
you're [__] stuck you don't know what
to bring people you ever been in the
aisle wine aisle at your local store and
you're staring at a massive selection of
wine and you got no idea what bottle to
choose from I mean everybody's done that
most of us go with a bottle that has the
best looking label and hope it's going
to be good well those days of playing
Russian roulette with your wine
selection are over Club W is a
revolution revolutionary new wine club
that takes the guesswork out of choosing
your one they have a simple six question
pallet quiz that you'll match you with
delicious high quality wine you're
guaranteed to love so it's six questions
that's it and next thing you know
they're giving you selections and ideas
and menus they open up a whole world for
you and the best part of it is that club
W will actually ship your wine straight
to your door no more going to the store
and being lost in the wine aisle like a
[__] one of those people from The
Walking Dead like those [__] again
that ends right there all right so what
I want you to do is this instead of
doing this [__] because remember time is
money you know you can get hit by a car
tomorrow and then you wanna what do I
get [__] yelping like Lee you don't
need that aggravation
go to Club W right now we're offering
you 20 off your first order when you go
to clubw.com Joey right now and it gets
even better I know you have paying for
shipping bam Club W actually pay for
your shipping on orders of four bottles
or more listen we cut out the middleman
it's from the [__] grower direct to
your door that's how Club W works all
right so take say take something off
your to-do list get four bottles let's
say you take two of the barbecue you say
one for Halloween and you save one for
Thanksgiving who's [__] better than
you so do me a favor go to clubw.com
slash Joey I'm Gonna Give You twenty
dollars off your first order right now
again that's Club
w.com slash Joey go get the one you
deserve four bottles Bang there you go
you got your [__] holidays coming
nobody needs to bother you no more and
you know what you end up looking like a
[__] Savage because nobody else is
getting this fantastic wine at this
price but they don't know that they
think you paid more go to Club w dot com
slash Joey right now I'd like to thank
my little beautiful [__] Cuban cousin
here Becky Gonzalez whatever her [__]
name is and my main man lisaata does not
know what [__] plan he's on tonight
you're going to rehab tomorrow it's over
we gotta get you to pick a different
last name for me what every day who
gives a [__] I don't want them to know
your real name on Facebook trying to
[__] fill you up and [__] you know
what I'm saying
thank you for protecting me well you
gotta look out for our own how you doing
my little brother I'm doing fine yeah
you know why you this atmosphere because
you have a training on the weekend
last night [__] around
[__] around
Marshall today I'm doing fine that's why
he's not looking that bad there's some
colors going around but I'm doing look
at him he's falling asleep you weren't
looking at them I'm looking I'm watching
like a hawk he's falling asleep I feel
like I've seen worse yeah get it
together [__] suck I love you guys have
a great week thank you for starting out
the week with the church
uh listen September 15th Austin Texas
September 24th and 25th New York City
got them Comedy Club you bad
[__] see you Wednesday stay
black don't tell nobody I don't [__]
love you because I love you [__]
it's a musically I don't care
remember
foreign